dans le cadre de ce type de
développement de projets comme pour tout
type de projet que vous pouvez avoir
vous avez des des des procédures
réglementaires qui sont mises en place
et donc on a fait l'objet de dans le
cadre du développement de ce projet de
demande d'autorisation et dans ses
demandes d'autorisation d'un notamment
une demande d'autorisation au titre de
ce qu'on appelle une installation
classée de protection de l'environnement
comme vous pouvez la voir par exemple
sur la sahara on l'avait aussi sur
antigaz vous l'avez sur d'autres et
c'est ce qui permet justement de
travailler sur ce que vous appelez vous
le danger en gros l'objectif principal
est d'identifier quelles peuvent être
les risques dans le type de
fonctionnement de cette centrale ça peut
être des risques pour ce qui concerne
l'ammoniaque qui peuvent être à la fois
lorsque l'ammoniac et liquides lorsque
l'ammoniac et en vapeur ça peut aussi
concerner des risques qui sont étudiées
sur des fuites partiel ou sur des
ruptures totales également sur les
système d'échangeur etc
l'objectif est bien d'identifier les
différents risques et de face à ça de
trouver et de mettre en place et les
solutions pour les maîtriser c'est
exactement ce qui a été fait dans le
cadre de l'étude de danger donc qui a
été produite cette étude de dangers a
d'ailleurs fait l'objet d'une contre
expertise de la part des services de
l'état
et c'est ce qui a aboutit donc à la
prise par le préfet d'un arrêté icpe en
février 2010 est donc il ya maintenant
un an dans lequel on a 44 pages de
prescription pour que la centrale puisse
fonctionner comme je le disais tout à
l'heure comme tout type de centrale
comme vous l'avez aussi sur la sahara
par exemple vous avez des prescriptions
l'assurance sur le papier mais que sur
le papier
alors non pas que sur le papier puisque
dans
le système même tel qu'il est mis en
place on travaille notamment vous savez
que à l'intérieur de la plateforme vous
avez quatre modules qui sont totalement
indépendants chaque module à son propre
système de sécurité est l'objectif à
travers les systèmes de sécurité qui
sont même redondants et d'éviter
justement et tout risque et de maîtriser
toute difficulté qui peut apparaître le
cas le plus extrême
il y a une très grosse rupture dans les
canalisations et que c'est à rognac s'en
aille qu'est ce qui risque de se passer
alors dans les différents cas
effectivement vous avez différents
scénarii qui peuvent s'appliquer dans le
cclat xtreme c'est notamment une des
raisons pour lesquelles vous avez un
seuil de protection qui est de 185
mètres autour de la centrale
ce seuil c'est la même chose je prends
excusez moi de prendre toujours
l'exemple vis-à-vis de la sarraz ou
vis-à-vis d'autres c'est exactement la
même chose que sur les autres sites qui
sont classés en seveso seuil haut c'est
à dire que vous mais moi en tant que
particulier je ne peux pas rentrer sur
ainsi pouvoir toucher directement les
installations ou être à proximité des
installations en dehors si le risque
était beaucoup plus élevé que ça c'est
les services de l'état croyez moi aurait
défini un périmètre qui aurait été
beaucoup plus large